on y va premier binôme c'est donc jean
michel lemaire contre eux géraldine ou
là jean michel lemaire géraldine alors
attention attention vous devez trouver à
lapins dorés venez l'amener là non mais
à mon top non mais eksi d'allô prof fait
une tête de cul non mais ne riez pas une
course
faut juste cherché à la comprendre mais
qui croule lapins dorés prend le salaire
de l'autre attention c'est parti
top asie go déjà lors elle n'a pas
d'oreilles qui est qu on n a pas vu mais
maitient des trucs partout jean michel
c'est gagner mojo bravo il offre à
gérald vallet pas que vous allez vous
mettre en place à les états castaldi
allez-y faites le à libération c'est dur
à faire allez on finira par isabelle
déjà qu'ils fassent attention
trois deux un top photo à la penderie à
lapins dorés tensions dans son hôtel
chic chuchote à la presse que talla parc
qui moi oui j'ai comme d'ajoie rien
et elle nous a pas fait la balade dans
la marre de ces bâtons mais c'est quoi
ce délire fait qu elle limitera lizzy a
été retrouvé à la fin dont le premier
qui trouve le lapin doré repart avec le
salaire de l'autre à ça ça m'intéresse
bah oui surtout castaldi est mis en
marche mais ça chauffe là bas où elle en
plateau on va vous de juillet à la main
par là et ça me va très bien
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine celui qui troublent lapins
dorés gagne le salaire de l'autre
allez-y non non non non l'avant et y est
roi
c'est vrai quoi froisser fera quoi non
non non c'est froid non jean-luc reste
plutôt à gauche mais ces deux malades
allez-y vite vite vite vite moati
seconde à nantes et froid la six fois
mais son action s'est pas lâché ya plein
de chocolat
mais non les mecs font rigoler les
galops c'est le choc a sauvé des flammes
cette affaire alors je me casse les
[Rires]
pieds il avait décollé arrêts et la
bombe
ça antoine il se dit mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fait c'est georges et on y va
bah oui c'est direct
[Musique]
[Rires]
et c'est vous les mêmes tâches à rigoler
la foule elle a voulu me casser la
gueule